se siete stati attirati da questo titolo
molto probabilmente vi trovate in
compagnia di un manipolatore o siete di
curiosi e si sa cosa si dice della
curiosità le uccisi molti più del
coltello
la domanda è molto semplice come fare a
capire se sei fidanzata con un
manipolatore questa persona mi fa
credere che sia difficile amarmi perché
effettivamente adesso è una cosa molto
molto tosta partiamo da un identikit e
il manipolatore fondamentalmente è un
grande e insicuro che forse si reputa
superiore alla maggior parte delle
persone ma che non riesce a raggiungere
la perfezione che vorrebbe tanto avere e
quindi si trova un pochino in bilico tra
la profonda inadeguatezza che il suo
narcisismo gli dà perché se tutti quanti
cerchiamo di paragonarci a un premio
pulitzer a un nobel tutti quanti saremo
dei [ __ ]
ma allo stesso tempo la sua fortissima
presunzione nel dire che comunque
avendole media dell'otto po pisciare in
testa a tutti quelli che vanno dalle
sette e mezzo in giù un manipolatore e
fondamentalmente è una persona che ha un
forte bisogno di controllo molto
probabilmente perché di controllo
all'interno della sua vita che sia
esterna o ancora peggio interna non ne
ha il primo grande passo secondo meglio
il manipolatore è quello di cercare di
conquistarsi in tutti i modi e la cosa
che io ho notato è che viaggia questo
tentativo di conquista sui due binari
uno che è veramente da film ti prendo e
ti porto via ho bisogno di te e che
quindi automaticamente ti metto un
pochino sul piedistallo dall'altra parte
il manipolatore usa il binario
dell'empatia alla prima cosa che fa un
manipolatore è raccontarti i traumi
della sua vita da una parte crea un
legame dicendo io voglia tenta d'altra
parte crea l'alibi dicendo venire in
mente il set più leggera e poco importa
se di lì a poco la pasta in relazione si
trasformerà dato che come grey's anatomy
cerchi di aiutarlo a lui che come
hannibal lecter ti divora completamente
ma proseguiamo con un minimo di
struttura dopo un primo momento che già
dovrebbe farti tanto pensare io non
incollato ricomincia a cambiare
leggermente atteggiamento noterete che
se all'inizio andava bene tutto quello
che facevate incomincia a trovare pian
piano delle piccole occasioni di
fruizione delle scuse per litigare
legate a dei comportamenti che poi
avrete comportamenti magari innocui che
sia una chiamata che non arriva che se
una parola detta male che sia una
qualsiasi azione alla quale
aggrapperà al fine di passare come
vittima ora i manipolatori partiamo dal
presupposto che non riuscendo ad avere a
che fare con l'infelicità che hanno
dentro devono per forza proiettarla
sugli altri è un pochino come non so se
ve la ricordate la pubblicità della
vigorsol ma non ne vado sera c era un
pacchetto di gomme in cui la ragazza che
era grossa in spiaggia mangiandosi le
vigorsol vedere tutte le altre che erano
ancora più ciccioni di lei
e questa cosa faceva stare meglio il
manipolatore fa la stessa identica cosa
non scendo a confrontarsi con quello che
diciamo il proprio peso interiore cerca
di aggravare quello degli altri a fini
sentirsi più leggero lui cambia qualcosa
del suo status
assolutamente no ma lui viene in
relazione di quello che gli altri
pensano di lui quindi è molto importante
quello che lo circonda al fine di
sentirsi a posto con quello che lui
vuole il manipolatore è bravissimo a
insultare invece di scusarsi cosa che
gli viene difficilissima anche per una
generosa dose di orgoglio e allo stesso
tempo incolpare invece che riconoscere
la propria parte di responsabilità per
quello che davanti a un problema che tu
gli poni riesce a spostare il focus
della tua attenzione ea manipolare
completamente gli eventi a suo favore
davanti a un ritardo invece di scusarsi
trova delle scuse che l'hanno portato a
fare tardi o magari la prima cosa che fa
in col parti di tutte le volte in cui tu
hai fatto tardi un'altra cosa che fa è
quella di esagerare il comportamento del
dire che sei la solita estetica che si
arrabbia per cinque minuti di ritardo
fondamentalmente una delle grandi armi
del manipolatore è quella di riuscire a
cambiare sovvertire completamente la
gravità delle azioni sue e del partner
grazie a questa azione il manipolatore
che avete a fianco diventa
particolarmente bravo a giocare il ruolo
della vittima fa scattare il senso di
crocerossina che in voi fa scattare i
sensi di colpa quello che fa innescato
meccanismo che fondamentalmente vi porta
non sentirvi mai abbastanza e quindi ad
agire come come se fosse un ciclista
alla fine di una corsa in continuo
affanno per cercare di prendere
posizioni posizioni che in realtà ti
porterebbero semplicemente allo zero al
pari è una partita di calcio e lui e 3
gol davanti a voi sempre se il gol lo
fate voi scatta il cartellino giallo o
addirittura il rosso
ci si colora molto senso si capisce che
non capisco il calcio se il gol lo fate
voi si chiede subito di visionare se c'è
stato un invasione se c'è stato un fallo
se la palla in realtà non fosse una
palla di cannone funziona come come
esempio di meglio del cartellino
vabbè andiamo avanti non esiste di
attacco in francia sarà un manipolatore
non esiste un punto di vista soggettivo
il loro punto di vista è universale se
tu la pensi come loro sei un cretino chi
non è d'accordo sta sbagliando è molto
semplice oppure non riesce a
comprenderlo e non si piegano finché non
ci arrivi anche perchè la loro
sensibilità li porta a comprendere
perfettamente fino a dove possono tirare
elastico e state sicuri che nel momento
in cui inizieranno a giocare le carte
più pesanti allegarvi a lui non ci sarà
un elastico molto probabilmente un
catenaccio un pezzo di ferro o un paio
di manette o un cappio cioè fate voi il
manipolatore vive tra il bianco e il
nero non riesce a comprendere che
all'interno di una situazione possano
convivere giusto e sbagliato bello e
brutto sì e no il più delle volte fa
passare per gioco infantile visionario
naif il pensiero che il mondo non si è
fatto di contrasti estremamente netti
una cosa che fa molto bene è sottrarsi
alle sue responsabilità se prendo un
impegno è molto bravo a tirarsene fuori
in maniera imprevista anche all'ultimo
momento adducendo sempre delle scuse
perché lui non sbaglia mai
e bravissimo a cambiare discorso ogni
volta che si trova ad affrontarne uno
che non lo vede preparato tutto quello
che non rientra nelle sue competenze o e
noioso o è stupido o non appeso i
manipolatori si chiamano così perché
tutte le vostre azioni o gran parte
delle vostre azioni col passare del
tempo incominciano essere influenzate o
suggerite da lui o da lei dopo che
queste persone sono sazi e una delle
cose che loro possono fare e buttarvi
accesso da un momento all'altro senza
dare spiegazioni
nonostante magari che abbiamo promesso
il mondo giurato amore eterno si siano
inginocchiati davanti a voi con un
anello pregando vi di sposarli o
dall'altro canto
per villani del manipolatore mandarla
scatenando altre due reazioni o la
totale indifferenza perché sempre il
bianconero si parla oppure la
disperazione e il dramma totale ofelia
che si annega nelle acque fino a che non
riescono a riaverli a questo punto
riparte tutto quanto da capo fino a che
poi non lo so molto probabilmente this
porzione di infilano all'interno dei
loro congelatori una cosa importante al
di là del fatto che questa descrizione
rientri o no nel vostro partner
una cosa importante sapere avere a che
fare con queste persone sono sicuramente
persone in uscite ma io il più delle
volte credo almeno spero confido prego
nel fatto che la cattiveria non sia
insita nella maggior parte degli uomini
e che il più delle volte le persone che
si comportano in maniera cattiva e
sbagliata sotto sotto non si rendano
conto di farlo questo non li
deresponsabilizza non li giustifica ma
sicuramente una parte mi permette di
comprenderli più facilmente questa cosa
mi ha permesso di perdonarli
assolutamente no ancora attende i
cadaveri dei nemici sulla riva del fiume
assolutamente sì ma da un certo punto di
vista magari non li voglio proprio
vedere smembrati dai lupi mi
basterebbero anche con un arto in meno
tutto questo per dirvi che la persona
che vi sta facendo del male la persona
che vi sta mettendo una gabbia la
persona che molto probabilmente sta
cercando in tutti i modi di farvi
comportare come volete voi o di farvi
sentire insicuro o di farvi sentire di
non essere abbastanza non si sente
abbastanza è insicura e si è messa da
solo all'interno di una gabbia qualcuno
che di voi avuto delle brutte esperienze
potrebbe dire fuori non sono solamente
la tua cavia da laboratorio io concordo
con voi
alcuni di voi invece magari non riesco a
uscire da una relazione di questo tipo
perché da una parte la vogliono
tantissimo a dall'altra parte si rendono
conto che come una brutta ubriacatura
che il giorno dopo diventa una sbornia
assoluta questa situazione vi fa male
ecco un consiglio che vi dò io è quello
di cercare di uscirne in tutti i modi e
l'unico modo veramente che se non
funziona è quello di troncare
completamente la comunicazione alcuni di
voi magari vogliono evitare questa
persona ecco quello che vi consiglio di
fare prima di tutto mettervi davanti
allo specchio e chiedervi lo sto facendo
perché all'interno del mio dna
e presente una persona che deve cambiare
il mondo che deve aiutare o lo sta
veramente facendo per dare una mano a
questa persona perché qualora risposta
sia prima andate uno psicologo e
smettetela di cercare di salvare il
mondo se normanna perché salva prima te
stesso che molto probabilmente stai nel
peggiore di tutti noi
ma se invece la vostra scelta è quella
di aiutarlo dal secondo contro di vista
sappiate che non potete farlo da soli
perché molto probabilmente vi trovate
già all'interno di una situazione in cui
ogni posta attenzione ogni vostra
lacrima è un cicchetti know di sambuca
alla fine di un lauto pasto per l'altra
persona il vostro dolore fa stare bene
quindi se veramente volete fare del bene
al vostro ragazzo la vostra ragazza
sappiate che quello che dovete fare è
convincerli di farsi veramente al di là
degli scherzi aiutare da qualcuno il mio
può sembrare un discorso forte ma
sappiate che è molto forte e può essere
l'impatto dei manipolatori all'interno
delle vite delle persone e chi ha avuto
a che fare sicuramente non potrà darmi
torto
tutto questo per augurarvi in bocca al
lupo spero che voi non vi troviate
all'interno di una situazione di questo
tipo spero di cuore che voi non siate
questo tipo di persone detto ciò la
seduta è finita su 60 euri ci vediamo
alla prossima ragazzi basate tra
parafuoco 60 euro e porgono si menano
qualifica alcune molto probabilmente ci
sarà uno psicologo qua sotto che mi
dirai che lo sbagliato tutto quanto anzi
ammetto così perché che non si dica che
sono umile se qua sotto ci sono persone
al di là di quelle che sono i miei
pareri dei villini esperienze e i miei
pensieri che veramente hanno studiato in
maniera approfondita questo tipo di casi
che sicuramente non possono essere
assunti all'interno di un video così
breve vi chiederei gentilmente di prima
di tutto dare dei pareri ai ragazzi che
magari ne chiederanno anche a me qua
sotto ma soprattutto aiutarmi a
completare e integrare o magari anche
correggere determinate cose che sono
state dette omnes all'interno di questo
video detto ciò credo che veramente si è
arrivata alla fine a questi sono i più
si sono 70 euro ha detto ciò non so
perché ma sto praticamente finendo con
la faccia dentro il monitor ritorno
indietro e
mando un bacio ciao alla prossima